So let me show you a better
example of doing it.
So here's some input frames taken from,
I don't remember which campus that is,
okay.
And this is the background model, and
that's a pretty clean background model.
You'll notice most of the people
walking around have disappeared.
These people, of course, are still here,
because they've been
here the whole time.
Nothing is here, because these
people have, have walked through.
When I subtract the two images and
just take the sort of magnitude of the
value, it's a little hard to see here.
I get sort of the general value here.
All right.
What I can do is I I
can threshold those.
I say, which points are above
a particular value?
And those are the points that light up.
I can then run,
what's called a morphological operator.
We're going to do that in
just a couple of lessons.
It's just a way of sort of
cleaning up binary,
and what I mean by binary images,
zeroes and ones.
Right?
I can then grow those
regions a little bit and
I can apply that and look at that.
This has pulled out
all the people moving around
in this area nice and cleanly.
With the exception, of course, of these
people because they've been there,
sitting there, so long that they just
look like they're part of the scenery.
All right?
And that's
what happens with median filtering.
Anything that stays there for a long
time just becomes part of the scenery.
That's actually considered
more of a feature than a bug.
Right?
So somebody parks their car and
pulls in and stays there for a while.
At some point maybe you don't
want to keep tracking it as an,
as an independent object.